was da gestern von der nasa und google
verkündet wurde war wirklich eine
riesensensation das könnte die suche
nach außerirdischen tatsächlich auf ein
paar jahre verkürzen zum ersten mal hat
die nasa mit unterstützung von
künstlicher intelligenz einen planeten
entdeckt unterstützt wurde sie dabei von
google genauer von google brain was das
alles bedeutet und warum wir jetzt schon
bald auf außerirdische stoßen könnten
jetzt den klicks in science fiction
herzlich willkommen
das thema künstliche intelligenz hatten
wir ja hier schon öfter mal alle großen
it konzerne forschen daran und es gibt
heftige diskussionen über nutzen und
gefahren anfang an waren elon musk und
stephen hawking vor der technologie mark
zuckerberg von facebook sieht er die
vorteile jetzt wird sie also zum ersten
mal bei der planeten suche eingesetzt
und das mit einer spektakulären premiere
für diese premiere ließ das
forschungsteam google brain anhand von
15.000 bestätigten planeten signalen
trainieren was genau auf einen planeten
hindeutet der nasa-satellit keppler
untersucht sterne nach
helligkeitsschwankungen treten die in
einem festen rhythmus auf zieht ein
planet an dem stern vorbei mit diesem
training erzielten sie eine 96
prozentige trefferquote bei google
bringen nach diesem training wurde
google brennt auf bereits schon
untersuchte 670 sterne angesetzt und
wurde tatsächlich bei kepler 90 50
google break fand in den daten einen
weiteren planeten dran sind um den 2545
lichtjahre entfernten stern spürte die
cas software einen achten stern auf zwar
ist der mit 400 grad celsius
oberflächentemperatur viel zu heiß aber
die sensation ist eigentlich eine andere
mit hilfe der software können jetzt
exoplaneten tatsächlich am fließband
aufgespürt werden bis heute sind es ja
schon knapp 3700 exoplaneten die in rund
2700 sternensystemen entdeckt wurden mit
google bringen könnte
diese planeten jetzt viel schneller
entdeckt werden jetzt müssen
forschungsteams nicht mehr selbst die
daten analysieren sondern das macht
google branding zukunft wir sind
natürlich müssen sie von den
forschungsteams bestätigt werden aber
die chancen dass wir erstens im nächsten
jahr tausende weitere exo planeten
entdecken sind riesig und das wir
zweitens auch gezielter nach
erdähnlichen planeten suchen können das
ist jetzt viel leichter möglich das
forschungsfeld kann jetzt so modifiziert
werden dass sich nur noch auf exo
planeten in der habitablen zone
konzentriert wird also da wo es leben
geben kann das james webb
weltraumteleskop das die leistung des
hubble-weltraumteleskops um ein
vielfaches übertreffen wird kann sich
dann auf diese planeten konzentrieren
das wird nämlich in der lage sein wasser
kohlendioxid und sauerstoff in der
atmosphäre der planeten aufzuspüren
beim vorbeiflug an ihrem zentralen stern
kann das teleskop das sternenlicht dass
durch die atmosphäre der planeten strahl
untersuchen und diese elemente aufspüren
während sie vorhanden wäre das ein
klares indiz für leben mit der vorarbeit
von kepler in der kombination in google
bringen könnten dann tatsächlich schon
nach dem status james webb
weltraumteleskop 2009 10 die ersten
planeten gefunden werden die dann
höchstwahrscheinlich leben beherbergen
die nächsten jahre werden also extrem
spannend wenn er kein video zum thema
und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr
auch immer über neue videos informiert
hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken chat mit einem toten
da geht es darum wie google bringt einen
toten als jackpot auferstehen lässt der
absolute wahnsinn ansonsten würde ich
mal sagen bis dann bleibt dran